oh
it was a
no-brainer I loved working on these
projects loved it and you know he told
me every three or four years that's all
it's not like when I was making start
right where I worked for seven years ten
and a half months of the year every day
from six o'clock until midnight that's a
very different experience this it's like
seeing an old friend who invites you to
his home for dinner every two or three
years
james mangold and his writing colleagues
for creating the movie we were
responding to it and bringing to it our
own
experiences and feelings about it and
one of the great things about James
Mangold director is that he comes with a
vision but when the actors begin to work
he lets their worth become part of
history
there are things yes and I should have
done very few I think my instincts have
always been quite sound about what I do
what I gender but i am very congested if
this is my history with this franchise I
couldn't be happy
[Music]
she's remarkable
she was delightful person good company
entertaining the music respectful in her
way she's 11 year old but her work as an
actress is
remarketing I've never seen performance
by someone so young he might've
committed serious involved free to try
things and experiments not just
following the directives instructions in
fact James Mangold will agree with me he
didn't actually have to give her many
instruction he just let her beat
the main difference was that
Star Trek seven years was every day
every week it was relentless and then
before the series was over we started
shooting the first movie and then
another movie at two year intervals it
was 14 years
x-men and will ruin he's been very
different there with longer gaps between
each one and I have not carried their
responsibilities in Star Trek where I
was the captain I was at the center of
everything Hughes the center of this
movie and we are supporting actor
[Music]
you